que son horaire était devenue la
réduction du temps de travail se taille
un franc succès auprès des salariés
davantage encore chez les cadres plus de
60% des personnes interrogées estiment
que la mise en place des 35 heures
entraîné une amélioration de leur vie
quotidienne florent muller et lætitia
fric pour bien commencer la semaine il
suffit de prolonger le week-end chaque
mois 6 millions de français pas tous
dans le bonheur des 35 heures les
marmots barbotte les parents par lot la
rtt c'est d'abord une amie de la famille
cardiff en tournage
c'est appréciable
qu'est ce que vous en faites de vos
jours de congés généralement
généralement on part en plongée avec les
enfants chez les marteaux du bricolage
la réduction du temps de travail connaît
le même succès 70% des français s'y
adonnent et les magasins ne
désemplissent pas ici les 35 heures ça
vous le clou on a obligé de pointe deux
jours de rtt par mois
voilà aujourd'hui c'est tombé
aujourd'hui voilà et qu'est ce que vous
allez en faire
eh ben je vais en profiter pour faire
tout ce que je te rappelle dans la
semaine par imad à voir se former le
week-end selon une étude menée par le
ministère de l'emploi 59% des français
estiment que les rtt embellissent leur
vie quotidienne tandis que 28% ne voit
guère la différence
mais pour certains sous le réconfort il
y aller fort et la rtt est dépensée à se
faire une santé pour les dure journée de
travail à venir un bien dans leur vie
professionnelle seuls 26 % des salariés
sont satisfaits des 35 heures près de la
moitié d'entre eux sont contraints à une
grande polyvalence est soumis à plus de
stress
l'extraordinaire c'est finalement de
pouvoir mener une vie ordinaire sauf
pour les salariés qui toute l'année
qu'il leur rtt comme des fourmis cela
pour ont chanté tout l'été sur ces
belles paroles il est tant d'autres